I'm pleased to report that situation in
general is stable in terms of radiation
I'm told it's the equivalent of a chest
x-ray
no Chernobyl is on fire interestingly
enough after Gorbachev retired he said
that the thing that brought down the
Soviet empire was that began at the end
of it was Chernobyl and they they
realized that this was a a small nuclear
event I mean he didn't actually explode
and it didn't ignite but that the
fallout from this nuclear accident was
so severe and that's what they get into
in the third and fourth episodes where
they're trying to clear it up and they
clean it up and I mean they're having to
they move literally moved the earth to
try and figure out how to get rid of all
this radioactive material that they the
Soviet High Command realized that they
couldn't actually conduct a nuclear war
because they would be impossible to
survive and that was the beginning of
the end of the Soviet regime one of the
things that's is sort of insidious about
the threat of it is initially when you
go into these environments you're
terrified but you because you can't see
it and you don't know what it's doing to
you very quickly become blasé to what
it's potentially doing to you and and so
people started to take massive risks
plus the Soviets were lied to and they
were told that if you drink enough vodka
it would protect you from effects of
radiation so they were handing out
bottles of vodka to everyone and they
were smashed absolutely smashed does not
protect you radiation poisoning just to
point that out it wasn't for your
character I mean obviously who is a
real-life person we talked about his
legacy and the effects it had on him
because he killed himself yeah I think
it was significant that the day that he
did it was the day that he was supposed
to go back to the
the Politburo and deliver another report
about how successful you know the hole
they dealt with the whole incident he
just he didn't want to lie again and he
was making a statement and then he was
trying to provoke his discussion about
within this scientific community to talk
honestly about what had happened and why
it happened because I think there were
at 20 nuclear reactors built to this
design around the Soviet Union and they
all had the same floor in them so any
one of them could could do the same
thing in fact when you know we filmed in
Lithuania and when Lithuania joined the
EU one of the conditions of them joining
the EU was there to decommission the
nuclear reactor they had and the legacy
of Chile was still being felt
international experts to this day still
continue to call it the worst nuclear
disaster in human history there may have
only been well I say only you know over
30 people killed directly but the
thousands of cases afterwards the you
know it is a lasting legacy to this day
the the birth defects in in Belarus and
Ukraine are just appalling and the
cancer rates of cancer there and
everything just appalling and they
aren't included in the official figures
but there's you know the real numbers
and the tens of thousands of people
who've either died or had their life
affected by and the children's life
affected by it
there is the whistleblowing element as
well yes and and just in light of recent
events to think about Cambridge
analytical the National Health Service
in this country what do you think the
message is in terms of the courage that
these people show to stand up to the
establishment and speak their truth we
should probably see these people as
being heroes it takes a tremendous
amount of courage for people to stand up
and say that they've seen something
wrong and that something should change
and again what we on the one hand you
rely on these people to stand up and act
on their conscience because they see
something's gone wrong and at the other
hand there's no great support towards
them and once they do that
that they they shouldn't be vilified and
their life shouldn't be ruined and their
characters shouldn't be assassinated or
their the people who do it are
tremendously brave because I don't think
anyone does that without knowing what's
going to happen and their life will
change forever what do you want people
to take from Chernobyl this this series
I mean we've talked about so much it
deals with so many issues but what do
you want people to take away from it
well I think that the the overall theme
of the story is how something as simple
as as a lie can lead to a catastrophic
result and that and we are dealing with
in that in that case a society that was
built on a culture of lies and deceit
that people had become cynical about
they notice didn't expect the truth and
you know that word itself now that the
truth is a it's a bit of a you know it's
a bit of a mind people argue over
whether things like it is the truth they
well they're very successful at
dismantling people's idea of their basis
or their rationale for believing in
something yeah that's a very dangerous
situation to get into if we're not able
to agree on whether facts is a fact you
know no as an actor where you stand on
the streaming versus cinema debate
that's raging a very successful series
Mad Men and the crown that are on
Netflix obviously Chernobyl is going to
be aired weekly on Sky Atlantic but
we'll be on our catch-up service as well
and there is this big conflict between
the Hollywood elite if you like and the
new streaming services that they can't
operate in the same space do you think
that they can you know that debate goes
all the way back to when television
first came out and it was chat it was
keeping people at home rather than going
to the cinema and
and specifically the way that this
debate is reignited itself it's it's
around awards and I I think you know you
they have the the people who hand out
the awards have the right to decide what
the criteria for entering into it is I
don't think obviously there's a space
for both experiences to exist and I
think that one of the reasons why the
streaming services are so successful is
that their content is geared towards
adults who'd find it hard to get out and
it's part of the reason why I feel that
we are experiencing this golden age of
television is they are able to satisfy
an adult demand for content you know
which demands greater storytelling more
complex storytelling